well joining me live now from Pico
Valletta in Spain is Hina Volker
professor for astral particle physics
and radio astronomy and part of the
telescope team and a very good evening
to you professor you must be very
excited I want to start at the beginning
here because everyone I've talked to
today about black holes not sagely
pretend they know what they are you ask
them to explain it they haven't got a
clue and how in lay persons terms can
you give us your description of a black
hole well actually a black call is not a
hole it's actually a whole lot it's a
lot of stuff in a very small space press
together and so the gravitational
attraction is very strong so strong that
even light will disappear in the black
hole light will be attracted and
disappear behind an event horizon and
will never be seen again so if you fall
into a black hole will be fantastic
adventure I think but you will never be
able to tell anyone because you're not
able to send any information out from
black hole radio waves or light where do
you go are you trapped in it are you
destroyed or do you come out in another
dimension or what Wow who knows you know
nobody has done the trip yet so we don't
know in principle you'll be actually
crashed into a infinitely small point
until the rest of your life you're gonna
be crushed and crushed and crushed
forever you're gonna be smaller and
smaller and smaller that's at least the
idea you have to test it and that's why
you have to do these experiments in fact
you may actually survive falling into a
black hole if it's just big enough and
so yep but I'd rather stay on the
outside and look at it rather than
falling into it so it's all a theory
though isn't it because we've never
actually seen one and this is the
attempt to actually lay eyes or well lay
telescopes on one yes we've seen actions
of black holes we see you know plasma
flowing out we see a lot of light coming
from a central region we think there are
black holes we see stars going around a
black hole with enormous lehigh speed
ten thousand kilometers per second
pardon my units and we think that you
know in the very centre of our Milky Way
there is this mysterious object this
this black hole but indeed we have not
seen what I've just described that
actually light disappears forever and
that's you know why you need to make an
experiment you need to take a picture ok
so why does this experiment add to the
the power of vision I suppose and why
hasn't it been tried before these
telescopes have been around these hugely
powerful observatories have been around
for a while yes it's it's part
technology and it's part realizing what
you need to do in fact I did my PhD on
this and at some point I realized oh
look this emission it's radio emission
at very high frequencies comes from near
the event horizon
you know that's light that just about to
disappear can we not see this at the
time the the technology wasn't ripe
enough enough because you need a lot of
digital equipment at telescopes what we
do we actually combine telescopes around
the world and they form a virtual
network at the highest observing
frequencies available to us today and
only now this is about possible but then
you actually get a resolution a
sharpness that allows you to see a
mustard seed in New York from from the
Netherlands from Nijmegen where I you
know I teach so what do you expect to
see I mean are we going to actually get
an image are we gonna watch see a lot of
a lot of stars shining brightly and then
a big black blob in the middle well sort
of that's the expectation in fact that
you indeed see a black hole you know I
call it the shed over black hole and and
some ring of fire around it but you have
to remember this is the first experiment
and the resolution it's just good enough
to see something let's see see a little
dip in the very center so it's just
gonna be you know a few pixels across
but of course with time this make become
better and then we may see actual you
know a shower bring and so we need more
telescopes and in part by the hair after
it correct you we only have a telescope
at the moment at six different locations
not 12 we'd love to have 12 and if you
know one of your gracious viewers out
there you know gives us like five
million euros we can build another
telescope in Africa to expand the
network and make it even sharper but
right now it's only six mountains and
eight telescopes I'll see if I know
anyone
but I mean are you prepared given that
it's theoretical at this moment are you
prepared perhaps to be disappointed to
have the theory of black holes disproved
many many hundreds of years ago everyone
thought the earth was flat and then
Christopher clock Columbus proved it
wasn't absolutely I mean I'd be
absolutely thrilled to be disappointed
in this case actually I mean so far when
we ever have tested the theory of
general relativity it has you know it
has survived Einstein had always was
always correct
so proving Antron wrong would be would
be just great I just don't believe we're
gonna be able to do this with just one
experiment but we know we know that near
the event horizon something got to
happen because quantum physics and
general relativity the two big theories
at the stripe our universe do not go
together at the event horizon so some
new theory has to come out whether that
experiment can help to to to to to do to
find out what that is I don't know but
at least we can make the very first step
to do an experiment okay well well to
talk to you afterwards best of luck with
it professor very good to talk to you hi
no Falconer